attention of human beings is the asset
you got your perspective what's up
everybody this is an epic - our Q&A
session from Phoenix where we just
completely brought down the house this
is the long form concept that you've
been begging for enjoy enjoy enjoy happy
holidays you often see people get caught
up in thinking that whatever their thing
is has to be a hundred million dollar
endeavor versus saying you know like for
me and farming in southwest Missouri in
rural area I mean if I if I had grew
something to a couple several just a few
million dollars here I mean that's it
that's wildly successful do you think a
lot of people focus too much on them yes
it's my note it's my favorite thing to
talk about like if you make what's wrong
with 137 thousand a year if you're happy
and you enjoy the [ __ ] out of it and
that's real money to you yes I do
but that doesn't mean anything to you
meaning ninety percent of the marketing
establishing world the mad I don't know
how many of you watch Mad Men or know
what an advertising agency in New York
City is ninety percent of that world
thinks I'm full of [ __ ] why because
they're holding on to the past and I'm
dangerous because they make money
selling newspaper ads and billboards and
television commercials they think I'm
full of [ __ ] because 90% of them that
work in those companies believe in their
religion
do you understand they don't know they
went to school they paid they don't it's
subconscious bias its subconscious bias
they went to a good university they work
at Oberlin or McCann or widen Kennedy or
Crispin port like they don't know they
believe in their truth they think a
30-second commercial is worth spending
millions of dollars huh like that's what
they believe they believe that I'm a
snake oil salesman yet they go home and
watch Netflix and stay on Instagram all
day
I mean it I mean it they they say things
like luxury doesn't work that way Gary
right like vogue we need a fog full-page
ad not in my business not in - not my
demo yeah listen everybody gets asked
you're the reason we have time is ask
your question nuances will filter so my
question is going to a place where when
you do take on bed
yes talking about yep I don't take on a
lot of dead just because I'm at a place
where I don't need to write and as your
debt in the form of a loan or credit
line or things if we're buying a bunch
of house it also depends on you know
certain structures I mean it depends on
what it is right so actually loans
versus credit cards versus personal
loans of the company okay do you ever
get does that ever weigh on you it's the
scariest thing on earth right your this
is why so many people in your business
going to business you're the ultimate
cliche you came in when the market was
[ __ ] you had less to lose crushed it now
you get high in your supply you get over
leveraged look guys it happens in one
day tomorrow you wake up it just happens
you do know that I mean like however you
you don't know how are you definitely
not but the rest of everybody else here
cuz you haven't lived it yet you didn't
live it you didn't live it you didn't
live just waking up and the April stock
market crash of 2001 and it's over you
didn't live 2008 Bear Stearns you heard
about it
you might have heard something your
daddy might have been upset you heard
something he didn't give a [ __ ] you
didn't live it you live I woke up in the
morning that day I was in I was in
France buying line and Brandon calls me
because if it's early you know six hours
ahead there it happened in the morning
Bear Stearns they did it Brennan calls
me goes hey I was like hey he's like
we've had like four hundred thousand
dollars in pre-order wine cancelled this
morning I'm like okay right
like literally I remember where I was I
started buying less wine
like then I did the first two days of
the trip you know first two days our
trip and big shot like AB don't take a
hundred cases of that I don't think 15
case of that literally an hour late I'm
like yeah this is not that great thanks
for your time so so yeah bro I would I
would hide and listen you're no dummy
dead is awfully scary if your business
doesn't do well when the economy
collapses if yours does look I think
vaynermedia explodes I do because I
think when Aquafina wakes up and
realizes and it happens in a day
remember it takes 30 to 60 days for it
all to get figured out but it happens in
a day and when they get into a board
meeting on March 9th and they're like
okay we had a we had 83 million in
marketing this year now that's been cut
to 9 million what are we doing with that
money I have a funny feeling that Gary
Vee character might know what to do with
it way better than [ __ ] Madison
Avenue student who's critiquing me and
so I think we're gonna explode but I
think your business won't well correct
correct you could you could do a ton of
stuff but it depends on how the debt is
compounding right I get it and you have
these opportunities look if we were
partners I'd be like bro honestly here's
my plan it's been so good for so long
let's actually be humble as [ __ ] let's
just let's just actually hoard cash you
understand a million dollars in your
bank account today in the world versus
what happens when the world melts that
millions worth like four got it see what
it's an interesting perspective right it
matters bro and honestly at some point
you got to say it's no different than
like I don't know what the blackjack
[ __ ] rules are but I know that you
keep going and then at some point if
it's like 11 hands or 6 or I don't know
the [ __ ] rules but at some point like
[ __ ] I got like the math is just not on
your side anymore we are so deep in this
world of like inflated [ __ ]
it's night or two donors its $92 I think
so mainly because I think you're gonna
pick up [ __ ] for a [ __ ] penny on the
dollar and so like it'll suck right now
it sucks for me I'm Lea I'm sitting
around just watching sitting on cash
being like I'm an idiot like right but I
won't be at some point it's gonna happen
it's no different than 50 in a 50 year
window I don't give a [ __ ] it takes
another four years especially and this
is how I hedged it because I'm building
a machine that capitalizes on the other
side so I would actually tell you try to
think about that or build your personal
brand and start talking about the truth
of I came in when [ __ ] was terrible it's
been really good I don't know when the
other [ __ ] happens
but let's interview people that were the
me in 2007 who thought they were big
shots who are now social media experts
or cryptocurrency experts or cannabis
experts cuz they got blown the [ __ ] out
by real estate cuz in 2008 they were
feeling great they went the other way
than what I'm telling you and over
leveraged themselves did their biggest
project ever
and then Bear Stearns put them out of
business yep you pick up those little
charms and create a story yep it can be
done online but where I'm really
struggling right now is till we train
our team just retrain this these 40,000
women do I train them to do your
business your way and show three ways to
be successful do I say hey all this is
old school you've got to stop doing that
and how quickly do I try to shift them
into all social media or online selling
Mike come on my MA if I was a partner I
would say number one way more than
number two with a kicker let them let
them let them do it their way I'm a huge
fan of self-awareness I'm a huge fan of
not putting I'm a huge fan of putting
people in a position to succeed some
people are just fabulous
when they invite the neighborhood to
their living room and other people want
to lay on their bed with green greeny
light and just be like buy my [ __ ] and
people buy that that way so I'm big on
letting I'm big on their way ,
it's you know it's my actions over my
words I'm big on do it your way right I
do it the best way that you communicate
on social platforms PS LinkedIn works
better with writing so to me it's your
way , our corporate point of view of
where the fertile ground is is the
following and before you say no try to
say yes you don't like to do Facebook
but you're a 40,000 a month kind of gal
then [ __ ] hire somebody what would
you recommend if you were my business
partner and you knew where we were and
we had wild success huge your axe and
now we have leveled out we're building
again what would you do how would you
sell our jewelry with knowing we have a
40,000 person face you mean how would
you sell the people that are selling it
to be more progressive or how would you
encourage our people to sell in 2018
what would be the advice I would give
him to sell versus them what should we
do to inspire him to actually do my
advice I would tell him to sell him
instagram stories and on youtube and
podcast everything i put out every day
the internet's the real world the real
worlds the fake world that's my [ __ ]
answer and the quicker people start
understanding that the quicker their
behavior will change i understand how
ideologically fun it is to think of an
old time when you read your [ __ ]
newspaper with a coffee and the world
was nice and slow Mazel Tov that doesn't
exist anymore there used to be a time
when we used to shoot a [ __ ] elephant
and eat it raw like it's over I'm sorry
it's not [ __ ] 1949 anymore
so you would encourage so if he were one
of my designers
yep you would encourage him go social
from the business model your business
your way if this is what you love but
hey before you say you're only going to
do it this way try this and from a
corporate perspective we train from a
corporate perspective I would quadruple
down on in-person events and content to
inspire our team the sellers it's you
know it's like this do this do this do
this versus hey come here let me show
you how to do this those are two very
different things it's very cute for you
to make a forty second one second video
and me to say go do it it's different
than like actually like okay and on
Monday we're gonna train you how to post
an Instagram story and in Tuesday we're
gonna Becky Thompson you know mama bear
on Instagram showing how she did and on
Wednesday we're gonna do this and don't
forget this Saturday in Atlanta Dallas
and El Paso worth the holiday in with
doing [ __ ] physical workshops correct
a hundred percent outside of your world
because you don't want to put pressure
on other sellers who think that you're
forcing them to give up their
competitive advantage which will dilute
their advantage encourage them through
some sort of contest or something for
like the most on you you could but what
you're doing then is you're creating bad
behavior one of the things that people
don't understand about the psychology of
people is short-term incentives or
short-term incentives it you know the
quality of your customer matters the
quality of your employee matters the
reason I don't have a one-size-fits-all
for my employees is D rocks not
motivated by title but I have 137 people
that are
137 people so it would also be really
good for us to track that we suggested
but how do you get the 137 people they
don't want to be the old marketing
agency that can think new and fresh
because the majority people college
actions by actions by your act by
putting out the content I try to
convince no one I just end up being
historically correct so hiring whoever
you hire on your team internally how do
you not get the old school how do you
find the people without the old I got it
ready all video people look at you like
when you got a print and a tin bow like
you said
my thought by firing the answer to a
question is a very interesting question
I don't I didn't know what the [ __ ] the
rock was gonna do I was just prepared to
fire him after 90 days if he wasn't good
the answer to hiring is actually firing
didn't have the Seattle Seahawks won
their Super Bowl they kept cutting the
fiftieth 250 third guy on the team
consistently and kept picking up new
guys until 52 53 can also contribute it
was very smart and that's how I think
about it it's what Jack Welsh did you
know he made it very ten eighty ten but
there's a lot of write to that and you
do a much better job up front to make
sure that people know they could get
fired like my big thing is kindness and
empathy and like a good culture so when
I'm hiring somebody very senior and I'm
involved in the process I'm like look
you're not gonna believe me you'd kind
of think I actually care about the money
you're gonna think that you're just
gonna come and contribute money like you
always have and I'm gonna look the other
way if you're mean in a meeting I'm not
so let me save you a ton of time go work
somewhere else this is my religion you
can do that about being a progressive
marketer got it so you put pressure up
front and then you deliver you bark up
front and you bite got it
to me it's it's very misunderstood
because from time of five to eighteen
we're told to go down this distribution
model and shove down our throat and so
for the entrepreneurs of the world it's
like okay you were that voice that like
finally stood up and said enough and so
dude I am so forever grateful I mean
what you've done no one could make it 25
hundred bucks a month three years ago to
making over a million dollars a year I
became 25,000 and I took it on the thing
and the old network markers hate to hear
this I work for them I'm great and and
I'm building a legacy around that that
I'm like yeah I bought all your [ __ ] cuz
it works the next step for you is the
problem with network marketing and I
have a lot of empathy for have 5 to 18
year old thing here's the truth of it I
mean otherwise I would do it full-time
the math doesn't work when you start
adding layers it just doesn't and it's
not how humans work like like to me I'm
gonna I'm gonna pitch you the 3.0 for
you where it gets really crazy is if you
to me I love a one-to-one relationship
that makes a ton of sense but when you
start playing with the math of what
happens when he goes and sells there and
what happens to me and things of that
nature you start getting into real you
want to talk about this you start
getting into really dis you get into
different incentives people are in the
business of selling people people you
know and what and and what as you know
you can't control that at some point the
end the end I don't want to say well no
this time though I get it that I
understand that's I understand that's
different but you I get it putting it
all the way because when the [ __ ] hits
the fan cuz it's going to my background
is in the former stockbroker
have a good understanding of the markets
and so on so forth it's coming the punch
in the face it's gonna be like the $92
it's gonna happen so quick I don't know
it's Black Swan or whatever we can't
control but I'm gonna be ready for it
this time yep go ahead good stories
we'll get to everybody got a brother
good it's just to put a bow on that too
many people spend time on strategies and
executions and systems that create
short-term behavior that looks good and
then becomes bad long-term behavior
twice as Inga went out of business in
theory it was it was great to acquire
customers on Facebook at such a low cost
but if you weren't creating something
that was keeping them so when you
incentivize behavior that isn't
naturally gonna be what the person's
doing it and they're doing it for that
thing it becomes the lottery you know
you like it starts you know like it's
it's communism Theory like you know it's
like you to me you bet on human truths
here's a human truth people are
incentivized by different things even as
an individual as they go through their
lives whatever system you can create to
continue understanding that and feeding
that at every I when I really talk about
being there for my employees like that
is just basically my life I just feel
like a much more Deion Sanders than I'm
Jerry Rice I am they're reacting to
everything I'm a counter-puncher
so I Floyd Mayweather was so good in
boxing
it didn't excite everybody it's not you
[ __ ] not like it wasn't Mike Tyson
it's just its defense it's perfect
defense it's reactionary so to me I'd if
you know if Karen like just loves
throwing house parties I don't want to
put guilt on her for not being on
Instagram but I don't want to not tell
her to think about Instagram and make
her say Karen being live on Instagram
couldn't feel like hosting a party
especially as we go into eight phases in
a screen like like don't sing no bet on
your strengths but don't say no like
like what Vayner at its best and what
our team is for sure is we're yes
culture
everything's just yes and and that's how
I hire I I don't take any pride in like
thinking I hire great I don't hire great
I hire um complete and utter intuition
which
sometimes works out remarkable and
plenty times does not
I'm just capable of firing because I
don't care about the judgment of making
the wrong call which bugs the [ __ ] out
of people it's a killer for people they
hire somebody they talk a big game to
their team that's been with them they're
like Rick's gonna [ __ ] kill it for us
then Rick's a [ __ ] idiot who came to
just like hang on and then my three
homies like you're [ __ ] wrong but I'm
like [ __ ] I don't wanna I don't I'm
gonna fix Rick because I can't be wrong
and from the homies ego its insecurities
with makeup brother so how did you get
through it the the sensitivity of lost
time if you got somebody I made the bad
bro the end the lost time is about to be
compounded if I don't cut bait right
this is why people lose money how why
would you ever either give away equity
or for a new company project or
something versus taking on debt to go to
your question to grow if you want to
grow if you need that money
salary somehow taking on debt is betting
on yourself more than taking hipping
away equity it's a safer bet to give
away equity yeah and then with that for
example that's super easy it depends on
how truthful you're willing to be with
yourself so for hiring people to allow
you to be you to be you starts with how
well do you know you you know for you to
be you you need to recognize what either
you like the most or what you're the
best at and the best is if you can
really hit the delta of the two like if
you're great at sales and you love it
you love the high of selling a lot of
sales people become CEOs because their
companies start to become a company what
they don't realize is they hate being an
operator and an executive they just love
being a salesperson but the humility to
hire a CEO to be your boss of the
company you started as a sales person
seems [ __ ] outrageous
not okay you are you're not cutting me
off so I am right in that point okay
trying to understand I am I've tried to
be self-aware so much that one of my
questions is like how do you are you
ever your own own worst enemy as you're
trying to be self-aware thinking did I
like second guessing something I've been
talking about a lot lately is the
inability to judge myself so the answer
is no that's where I'm really strong
I just don't dwell I don't judge I've
come to realize it has so much to do
with not caring about other people's
opinions so I don't second-guess myself
there's just no time
that was pretty in there that was pretty
in there but that then reinforced
through watching how it played out for
me for twenty years versus my dad versus
my brother versus lots of businesses I'm
involved all the interaction it's no
different than the lost time like it is
what like I do not calibrate I cop bait
emotionally and like mentally so quickly
that cuz cuz it's not valuable like you
made the decision but I get slowed down
in operating and executing on that that
level because in the process everything
else has to go like I value the setup of
the camera so I'm trying to do that
simultaneously to actually getting the
person to fit in the world the biggest I
think the biggest thing maybe maybe
d-roc no no this is perfect
I think d-roc just kind of caught his
reaction directly talk to me about
perfection or the idea of it yeah we're
just like I think like I think what eyes
and eye reaction was when you were
talking like first of all this is
something I don't say as often as I used
to just cuz it takes a lot of
explanation but like 99% of things that
going through your head right now about
your business don't matter I really
believe that that's a brain [ __ ] you
know
what he doesn't watch and I do so love
anything right out I mean even the
temper senators together but even though
he said that the content really matters
to him yeah he trusts you enough and
there was that one nope I trust a market
value like value the volume over the
debate it's it's an output game you back
to sports you can watch film all week
I've learned so much about football
because of the agency we have me and my
brother
you can watch film all week if you're
not able to execute on the field on
Sunday and some other guys been going to
the club all week and he can play on the
field on Sunday results speak my
articles don't go out so my articles
don't go out um I'm the bottleneck I
have to hear the new writer write it
because it's got to be me and I have to
you know video is me this is look at me
like you know I'm on the record I I that
and that's back to like why I was okay
with you filming like I'm on the record
I made that decision in 2009 everything
I do when there is no camera is on the
record especially now that I'm actually
known like now I actually know that to
be true there is no me doing anything
without somebody watching tonight maybe
though the two senses just to clarify oh
yeah
were you talking about the hiring firing
of these salespeople in that you're
handling that role in the Delta time
between you actually denying you need
you know go ahead my honestly it's
bigger than that in my opinion I just
think you're debating [ __ ] that doesn't
matter you're auditing yourself for no
[ __ ] reason out of a personality
trait and just being in the beginning of
the process my big thing is just [ __ ]
do do you know many people spend three
years doing because they don't know
anything about anything they get
successful and then they start changing
everything that got them there
almost everyone I go the other way I try
to get dumber here's here's the problem
family family businesses are binary
there's only one boss right and what's
so powerful about this conversation was
really funny the Delta of looking you
your 20 foot right so you know one of
the things as YouTube probably know if
you follow my content being younger like
I talk so much about patience and how
long life is and as he's talking just
watching your face was a lot of fun he's
talking about my you know you're saying
like kudos to you
meanwhile there's a [ __ ] older
generation in him in the [ __ ] game
right and I keep trying right and I'm
like trying to get people to understand
71 85-79 like life is long boy like yes
you could die of course he does so so
and this is where I talk about like
patience and like you know like I mean
it's just if there's so many dynamics
but I will say this for the four of us
and everybody was watching and for the
rest of us like there's only one boss
and where people get confused is in the
lack of clarity of that of the pictures
we paint in our own mind there's only
one boss and she or he is that boss and
until they say they're not and start
acting on it everything will be murky
and you have sons who are cool with it
he said it was tough for him to watch it
he was cool with it that he liked it is
that was his hero he was content he was
content with what he had others are not
I wasn't so I you want to talk about
bailing on an employee after you gave
him four months what about building a
business from three to sixty million and
walking away with zero how about nothing
guys Wine Library started in a
conference room of another company if I
had money I wouldn't have started it in
buddy media's conference room it was 34
years old nothing
I never talked about it because at the
time that this started all happening
with me I resented my dad about it it
didn't feel right to me 18 months ago
two things happened simultaneously which
is why I've started talking about it one
I was so in Silicon Valley corporate
like business that I lost the reminder
of what a family business is which is
it's the old man or old woman's business
until they die and then you get and I
forgot so that like all of a sudden in a
you know whenever I remembered I was
like wait a minutes not my dad's fault
this is just that game it's the old
school game that's the immigrant coming
to a new country game you build a [ __ ]
you die the kid takes said there's no
thoughts of capital [ __ ] gains and
[ __ ] income tax and inherent insect I
don't even know that [ __ ] these are
people that write on [ __ ] paper and
cash and [ __ ] who give us a [ __ ]
right so I got away from that and listen
I also was an extreme example I've
really built a huge business as a kid
gave up my entire childhood my hyperbole
is as real as [ __ ] you know you wake up
and you're 32 and you had no childhood I
had no childhood like let's get it very
very very real to this room from 14 to
34 I worked every minute 19:53 [ __ ] not
to like there was no pot I didn't go to
parties I didn't go on vacation so you
wake up and now you're walking it
doesn't feel great number two I was
starting to impact people and people
were using it as an excuse of why not to
listen to me and I had to create clarity
because I didn't want no people I didn't
want kids to follow [ __ ] losers
instead of me because they made the
excuse of not wanting to hear the hard
work part by saying well his dad gave
him so I was like I got a click
I got a creak I got a crate I'm getting
razzed for something I'm the extreme
reverse of I'm you know I'm the reverse
of entitled but real quick go back to
your business the thing I'm probably
most excited about is real life as the
world becomes Internet and real life
becomes fake it's the same thesis I have
on Facebook
as everyone's about to run away I'm
about to go back in I love real world
I'm obsessed with it there's a reason
concerts are up the movie theater is
doing tremendous we're so deep in our
shed that we do yearn we also do things
in real life now for the content people
literally hike and go to Disney World
for the picture there are fucked-up
families where the mom and dad are hate
each other that go to Disney to take a
picture in from the Magic Kingdom to
post on Facebook to trick people that
the family is okay of course it is but
guess what people are [ __ ] stupid let
me explain why face the [ __ ]
Facebook's not making you fake your fake
mother [ __ ] like you can shut down
your Instagram and Facebook you're gonna
be fake at the coffee shop you're gonna
be fake at the PTA meeting people are
fake people are fake because they care
about other people's opinions especially
people they don't even care about like
it's the most broken it's a lack of self
esteem now so anyway I'm obsessed with
real life show and as a matter of fact I
I don't know your business well enough
but if I'm back to your business to like
them like the like one thing I'm
obsessed with is extremes if I started
at events business if I was like in the
blowup Castro business to rent to like
bar mitzvahs and birthdays what I would
do tomorrow is go to [ __ ] China
and make the most extreme castle of all
time like a 900 foot castle because
what's happening in our society right
now is it's mine'll ISM and it's
extremism the Middle's [ __ ] some very
hot on like if you look at like the
pop-up museums in New York it's like
extreme candy extreme colors it's like
you've got these you know mocktails that
are like $39 but they steam out like go
extreme as [ __ ] cuz the picture if it's
the club dynamic why do clubs right now
have when you order the champagne the
sparklers come out and four people want
attention they're not buying the
champagne they're buying the attention
they want every dude and girl in the
club to look at me like oh that's the
big baller
in China it's got even more extreme
where they're doing like interactive
[ __ ] with QR codes where the cool guy in
the club throws money on the screen and
then everybody can QR and take it really
so hey I love real life be anyway you
can figure out to be the most extreme
err or the most subtle don't live in
don't live in the middle the world is
getting pulled that way because of the
Internet
it's the Middle's bad it's really huge
and then look at yourself to figure out
who you are the reason I think I work is
I'm a little bit of both right I'm very
outlandish in my communication style but
I'm very minimal in my likes right there
is no jewelry back to you said like
that's not who I am
and if I was that's cool I love
authenticity and II froze Ella loves
Lamborghinis for real and so that's cool
and he can afford them and he's not
renting them to look cool to like make
you pay for a thousand dollar course so
like that's authentic authenticity and
left the right know middle I love real
life
I think company should activate in more
real life where I was going and I
brought it up a couple times he's like
b2b companies [ __ ] buying ads in b2b
magazines for 20k doing $130,000 [ __ ]
build out an exhibit and telling me they
don't have $15,000 to run LinkedIn ads
on content we should have people
stopping you 2021 I'm not sure I'm
really not but it's gonna be way more
internet than not last mile is gonna be
here one day like just a great clarity
like everything you want is gonna be
delivered within an hour in America but
I mean but I mean for real
I and for there to like it's really like
to his point in New York and other
places sure but in nine years when it's
happening in his world and he's picking
up a bar of deodorant
cuz it's that's how we live or or the
bar of deodorant itself is reordering
itself because Gillette
putting you know technology in it and it
knows it's done and it's just being
delivered direct like it I don't know
and 20 22 21 is not that far away like
but what I can tell you is more internet
less real-world who the [ __ ] knows you
know this is what I've been talking more
about it lately we just I don't know I
know right now it's a good idea to be
using Instagram shop Shopify Amazon face
that's good just look at technology
think about what a razor phone that was
the coolest thing on earth in 2005 if
that put that in your in hand right now
what a piece of [ __ ] that would look
like non smartphone and what did she say
Mazel Tov I'm not artificial
intelligence is like so far away from
when I give a [ __ ] like I don't care
about anything that's not practical in
the short term why like there's too much
risk and like I mean it just it takes a
long time for technology to actually
click it is it is and I'm all about
voice and I'm super interested in that
and I've been obviously talking about it
I you know I think I don't get a high on
I don't predict I don't know to say I
don't predict I talk about Instagram
story ads right now are unbelievably
under priced you should run as much as
you can for whatever the [ __ ] you do I
think both work both work
but it's about it's similar to the
here's the answer they both work similar
to you know trade shows and marketing
but which one's better and more
opportunity stick at this moment is the
debate am I better off to have thirty
seven guys and gals on the phone closing
this and and having three film people
and running ads and my allocation is
seventy one percent of energy and
resources to the phone team versus
twenty nine over here or should it be
sixty forty got it that's the game you
understand
it's that practical everyone immense me
value and I've heard you talk about it
so many times a minute listen to it's
about leverage life is about leverage so
in a relationship the positive one has
the leverage over the negative one in
the long term but in the short term the
negative one has the leverage over two
positive one do you know any cliche
marriages and when the one that was a
dick for twenty two years is stunned
that out of nowhere the other one woke
up and said you know what [ __ ] you I'm
out and then they're like no no no what
the [ __ ] cuz the leverage is that with
the good one this is why I have all the
leverage there's a lie when everybody's
confused by me versus the other forty
five faces that pop up on pre-rolls and
ads I'm going to win cuz I'm bringing
the most value that's an absurd thing to
put out for free I'm aware it was not
just what I normally do which is easy we
put time and effort to like really give
it to you months so it was tight and
good and like the most basic person
could go through it eighty pages five
times like ah who helps you balance the
practicality of the financials
me it's the truth
when you have multiple streams income
where do you pull so I've like six
different income where do you pull a
salary when you have I mean you have way
more right like your honor
here I know where I'm currently I'm
thinking is that the right cuz I'm
revenue coming in for about six
different businesses that either have
equity ownership in what is your
guidance on that meaning so I always
invest in things that I think have like
I look at the year ahead not too much I
don't get too crazy
far out like if a business is growing I
feed it and so for me
one of the reasons I write books or
speak is it allows me to make income so
I can continue to invest in my
businesses and I try to keep my overhead
low which has been harder over the last
couple years just growing family just
like you know as time evolves you're
like you know after you eat you know you
heard my story 14 234 it's like you know
when I started giving the charity along
the way you might have heard the charity
water story I've mentioned a lot of
times where Scott's like don't do what
you think you're gonna do and give it
all away at 85 do it along the way I'm
like oh yeah that kind of affected my
real life too which is like you know
what maybe I shouldn't you know you know
as much as I do play for the long-term
it's not terrible to enjoy a little some
the leverage off of those people to
market to people that have other events
what I don't want to give up is is the
digital marketing side of it but I don't
want to continue to go too far like four
different directions with the business
at the same time does that make sense of
course it does the leverage is the the
leverage is having the practitioner ship
ability in the execution of underpriced
attention your question is answered in
what I'm doing for a living
very true look the [ __ ] am i doing I
believe in its so much that after having
unlimited leverage financially
reputationally I'm still doing it
if that's my answer it is good and and
more importantly as you know when
Facebook changes a as somebody who's a
real player I'm telling you I'm going
back in then there's gonna be to her
question in 2021 a new app called water
which is gonna be the number one app in
the world and it's [ __ ] Instagram
meets like an AR meet I don't [ __ ]
know but the game of all you did was
just tell a modern-day story of what I
did on Google for Wine Library it's what
you talked about earlier like the skill
of marketing and sales and getting
attention when it's a good deal at an
underpriced level can let you be a
[ __ ] wood sign maker can help you sell
[ __ ] jewel it is the ultimate thing
attention of human beings is the asset
what you deploy that attention to can be
low margin but you're passionate about
it can be high margin can be whatever
the [ __ ] you want
but there's the oxygen of a business
exploding right it's the oxygen of a
business exploding there's a lot you can
do cold calling that could be the oxygen
I'm talking about why do companies have
hyper growth because you bought
beachfront property in Malibu before
anybody understood it was beachfront
property in Malibu attention
well attention is great birthing
psychology to is knowing how they
actually which just gets me to the next
part which is why I was so quick to not
be pumped about data I can get in front
of everybody with information now tell
me what you're putting in front of them
I can low your CAC based on creative
yeah well that's what changed our whole
business of course that did realize of
course we went from one pricing model
and changed the entire thing and we've
now got quadruple the numbers how about
the fact that there's a video you
haven't made yet that will lower the
numbers even or double the numbers even
more it's the volume of content voice
you talked a lot about voice I do
because it's gonna take over search how
do you
boys and how do I mean I don't want to
say just apply to our business but howdy
I don't know yet because I because I
think Amazon and Google have
disproportionate leverage hey Alexa I
want to go to a race this weekend where
should I go you know expensive that the
next sentence from the machine is gonna
be a amazon's gonna be like [ __ ] you i'm
not gonna let you pay ten thousand
dollars a lead i'm just gonna create a
[ __ ] company put you out of business
you don't you better hope that they
don't want that model you just hope it's
not your turn the internet that's gonna
kill everybody
it just they killed taxi drivers first
[Music]
[Music]